I don't know if you remember truth or
fail you might you might remember that
it was kind of a great big fail well
that doesn't mean that I didn't like the
idea but it definitely didn't need to be
refined and so that is what I've done I
am happy to announce that John and I as
of today are relaunching truth or fail
and it's going to act slightly different
than the original truth or fail the
basic idea is the same we give you two
facts you choose the true one or you
fail but we've introduced some
modifications which should make the
whole thing run a little bit more
smoothly the most important modification
is that there are two truth or fail
channels there's the one that you should
subscribe to which is that youtube.com
slash truth or fail and there's the one
that you shouldn't subscribe to and that
second channel is where all the answer
videos go whereas the first channel only
gets the first video so no you will not
get 25 videos in your subscription box
every time a new truth or failed video
gets posted if you want 25 videos in
your subscription box you can subscribe
to the no subscribe channel but you
probably don't the other difference is
that truth or fail videos will be posted
in two places one on the hosts Channel
which is right now me and two at
youtube.com slash truth or fail now
you'll notice I didn't say that they're
just posted on the vlogbrothers Channel
that's because they're not just going to
be done by law brothers that's right
we're working on having lots of
different truth or fail hosts and I'm
not ready to announce who the first
not-me host is going to be but it will
be cool I promise you I'm excited about
it so most likely you are watching this
at youtube.com slash vlogbrothers but
you could be watching it at youtube.com
slash truth or fail and as new truth or
fail videos come out they will be hosted
by different people and they won't be
hosted at the vlogbrothers channel but
they will be hosted at youtube.com slash
truth or fail I don't know maybe anyone
youtube.com slash truth or fail that's
probably enough talking about this on
with the show
hello this is Hank green and you are
watching truth or fail oh yes it's very
simple I just read you two facts and you
uncover the truth or you fail you are
probably not interested in whatever else
I have to say so let us begin fact 1
strippers make more money while
ovulating when they're fertile than they
do in their menstruating when they're
not fertile or to Albert Einstein loved
playing Scrabble
you